[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and i
got with me chuck knight jack hey neil
all right chuck we do we do a lot of
explainers together yes we do but
sometimes we got to do explainers about
stuff i don't know anything about so
yes in that rare occasion
so we comb the countryside
and we are overdue for a show on monkey
pox
yes we so
are it's all the rage right it's all
rage it's in fashion the country's gone
monkey pots crazy you know and so uh we
found someone who was in high demand
we're just so delighted she could spare
a few moments with us for one of our
explainer videos um please help me
welcome professor ann remoyne an
epidemiologist from ucla and welcome to
star talk
thanks for having me yeah you're in an
endowed chair there uh a endowed chair
of infectious diseases and in public
health uh named uh gordon levin is that
one person or is that gordon like
gordon's law gordon levitt the actor
two very generous people
and so gordon and levin levin and levin
you got it you got it and you are
uniquely qualified to be in this
interview and enlighten us because
you've spent decades on monkey pox
before anyone's thinking you you're all
in it before anybody in the rest of the
world is thinking about it and you're
there in the congo the democratic
republic of congo where monkey pox was
prevalent
and so
we have a million questions so are you
are you just present or
like did you know this was coming or
yeah yeah she wanted to be ready for
this moment so therefore 20 years ago 20
years ago wait before we get into your
into all your business
um
does it say infectious diseases
on your business card like what's that
like when you hand it to someone do they
they don't want to
clean they no longer want to touch the
car
a little bit
they they immediately hand you the card
right back like disinfect you know they
corral their hands
so what's that like
well it's changed a lot over the last
couple years let me tell you in the in
the years before
the pandemic when you say
epidemiologists people would say are you
a skin dog oh epidermis oh yeah
was that that was the the discussion
beforehand now today
everybody knows what an epidemiologist
is we've hit the mainstream
so
very very different very very different
than it used to be and and you have
knowledge of value to people so that
gives that has boosted your currency
presumably uh out there right
yeah i think that people now actually
understand what an epidemiology tell us
put that on the map right for us right
now
well an epidemiologist is studying
patterns of disease in populations
so that's the point of epidemiology and
in terms of an infectious disease
epidemiologist i'm focusing specifically
on patterns of disease in populations
i'm under trying to understand what the
burden of infections are who's getting
them why are they getting them and how
you can prevent them
okay so
who what when and where why yeah yeah
yeah so that is the mantra of an
epidemiologist there you go so my my
area of expertise is really global
infectious diseases
uh and you know epidemiologists do a lot
of different things we're but
some of us specialize in something some
of us specialize in others i really
specialize in infectious diseases but i
started working on monkey pox when i
started working in the democratic
republic of congo in 2002.
and at that point i i had just finished
my phd i started working at the national
institutes of health and
because i had worked in eradication
programs i worked in vaccination
programs disease surveillance when i got
to congo i was a program officer
actually at nih working on a project
related to malaria and pregnancy and
pregnant women in kinshasa i sat down
with the director of the national
laboratory trying to understand the lay
of the land
who's also been in the news quite a bit
he is the the the congolese doctor who
really was the first person to discover
ebola in 1976 had been leading the the
work at the next you all know each other
as you must right otherwise you can't
communicate anything right
well i mean that was the first person i
sat down with i mean he he was really
wonderful and he started telling me
about this problem of monkey pox and
that there seemed to be a lot of cases
but at the time
nobody was interested in analyzing these
samples it's just monkeypox wasn't on
the radar everybody was busy with other
things and so i actually
took uh my per diem and helped send
those samples that have been sitting at
the national lab to a collaborating lab
in germany who analyzed them found out
that there was a lot of monkey pox in
there the supposition was as there might
be some small pox might sorry some
chicken pox
some monkey pox but but probably not all
that much we were very surprised at how
much monkey pox was there and so that
was really the beginning of this project
we demonstrated that there was a lot of
monkey pucks there and then we started
an entire research program together to
be able to really do intensified disease
surveillance and show that there was a
lot more there
you keep saying monkey pox i know i'm
i'm as a lay perspective by that too
yeah you just keep saying monkey pox and
uh i just want to know
first of all i mean i know i've done a
bunch of reading because it's all crazy
now wow you know everybody freaking out
and i know that it's you know a zoonosis
virus we know that it i i hear these
terms clades i hear this term uh west
african basin congo basin
uh what is all of this what is all that
well okay so
monkey pox monkey pox is a zoonotic
disease meaning it starts in animals uh
and
it resides in animals but can cross over
into humans uh monkeypox has
traditionally been circulating in in
animals in
sub-saharan africa it's it's a mystery
monkey box is a misnomer monkey pox is
called monkey puck swiss was first
discovered in in a monkey colony
a research colony in denmark in 1958 so
they called it monkey pox but it really
turns out this is a rodent pox so it's
no it's a denmark box
it is what's rotten in the state of
denmark okay
i see what you did there chuck thank you
okay
all right so sorry i i i we interrupted
you yeah please repeat that with denmark
so it's really a rodent pox okay okay go
on it's really a rodent box
and it uh it
it resides we we think that the
reservoir species are squirrels uh pouch
rats other rodent species it probably
actually infects a lot of different
rodent species uh but that's so monkeys
can get it from
rodents just like humans can right so
now so wait a minute let's look at this
chain of uh trans transference here
monkeys get it from the rodents does it
then mutate in the monkeys and then they
give it to us or do they just pass it
along to us
monkeys can be incidental hosts it's you
know in vrc
most often the cases
most of the cases are associated with
squirrels
uh
other other rodent species sometimes
people will pick up a monkey that may
have a rash on it
um may have been infected and they'll
get it from from eating a monkey but
really monkeys you know primates humans
non-human primates we're all incidental
hosts this is real virus that that
starts enrolling by the way you're
scaring the crap out of me right now
okay
go ahead you know i'm just saying maybe
because i'm a city person but you just
said oh if you pick up a monkey and they
have a rash they could be i'm saying i'm
never picking up a monkey right that is
not a thing that i ever think of doing
and piggybacking on that what neil just
said i'm thinking you know monkey pox
okay here's the deal i don't hang out
with monkeys i'm good okay like i'm
never i'm not gonna run into any monkeys
okay here in new york city so i'm okay
but now that you say it's a rodent pox
we're talking about rodents and
squirrels okay now i'm scared cause we
got a lot of those yeah yeah so
yes we do
and that's going to bring me i mean
we're you're already you're already
ahead of the story but let me tell you
that is exactly some of the things that
i'm worried about so here's what she
just what she just told you chuck is let
her finish the damn story
let me translate the professor's
comments i'm motivated by fear here i'm
sorry
go
go
so here's the deal i'll try and make
this this quick
so the the situation is this is that
monkey box has been spreading for a very
long time we didn't know monkey pox was
out there because it looks just like
small pox which is a cousin of monkey
pox and when we eradicated monkey pot or
smallpox from the planet we stopped
vaccinating against pox viruses and as a
result we started to see
some some chinks in our
herd immunity armor and so what happened
was is over time as people were no
longer vaccinated people
when they came in contact with a rodent
or a monkey they would get infected this
would be people below a certain age
right well it started out that what we
really thought of this was is a
childhood disease so in principle it was
children that were in contact with with
animals and actually the very first case
of monkey pox and a human was discovered
in the democratic republic of congo in
1978 in a old child who had not been
vaccinated and this was when they were
at the end of smallpox eradication they
were looking for every single case of a
pox-like illness and making sure that it
wasn't a case of smallpox that's part of
the certification process for
eradicating
yes
and so
that's how they discovered it was monkey
pox uh once they eradicated monkey pox
in here or smallpox in humans from the
planet what they did was they they
decided it's really important to
understand what's going on with monkey
pox here is this going to be important
is this something that's going to
fulfill the ecological niche we don't
know so they started a program in drc uh
to monitor it and really the vast
majority of the work that we that you
know is the basis of understanding
is from 1981 to 1986 uh in drc and it
was really mostly children because you
think about it if everybody was
vaccinated and they only stopped
vaccinating in 82
it was really only young children that
had any susceptibility to this virus
and that's why there's so little known
so when i got to drc
in uh in 2002
you know there were all these suspected
cases of monkey pucks and and a lot of
rumors of cases increasing and it made
sense because we no longer had immunity
so we started this project in drc
professor muyam bay and i together and
we started doing intensified disease
surveillance and we ended up having a
real understanding that there was a huge
increase in monkey pox since the 1980s
since immunization stopped so we wrote a
paper it was in the proceedings of the
national academy of sciences and showed
this this 20-fold rise in the incident
smokey pox since the end of smallpox
vaccination campaigns
and that should have been a big warning
to everybody because that just showed
that listen as immunity goes down and
exposure goes up you're going to see
cases go up let me go back a little bit
if
we all know many people know
that the immunity
that some milk maids had to smallpox
came from their exposure to cow pox
are you saying
that the people most susceptible today
to monkey pox are people young enough to
have not gotten a smallpox vaccine
because does a smallpox vaccine
protect you against monkey pox in
today's world
neil that is exactly what i'm saying
yeah
so how old do you have to be to have a
smallpox vaccine i've got a scar i got
my small part how about you chuck you're
10 years younger than i am
yeah i'm yeah i don't know 75 what's
that dude
you're too young
you've got a scar on your skull i got
one no i don't i don't have a scar
chuck were you born here in the united
states yeah
okay well then then you you wouldn't
have been vaccinated
in the united states stopped in 71. so
now how does it spread
so so wait a minute just another point
here that it it is
smallpox vaccination probably does
provide some protective immunity but we
don't really know how much in this
particular outbreak and because there
are all these different modes of
transmission that aren't the standard
modes of transmission that we've been
studying all these years and we just
don't know
for sure so chuck you don't you don't
have to feel
that jealous of neil you guys can both
be jealous of me i've been
vaccinated and lost i was vaccinated in
2004 okay so sooner than both of you
just because i work on monkey pods you
got you you got the industrial strength
super concentrated
yeah mpxv like solution
okay so this is this is on the skin so
can we presume it doesn't ever go
airborne
well i always say we we should be humble
about what we know and what we don't
know about this virus
what we know about this virus is really
as i mentioned before
really concentrated in those early
studies in the 1980s in villages in
remote rural villages in congo and that
is a very different context and so you
can imagine that the studies that we
have we have some animal model studies
we have a little bit of knowledge from
what happened in the 2000s there was a
small outbreak in the united states in
2003 47 cases from imported gambian rats
that were put into a facility next to
prairie dogs so
why would anyone import a rat what's
that
what's going on
monkeys and what is going on don't shoot
the messenger here i'm just
i'm just thinking of the sewer rats in
new york look this is our place
tell me about it import african rats
into the
how do we stop this well that's a really
good question so as we're talking about
these so the way that we stop it is we
have to get in front of it how do we get
in front of it we have to have really
good disease surveillance we have to to
really have good situational awareness
we have to have great testing testing
has to be widely available to everyone
that that even suspects that they've
been uh that they have potentially been
exposed you left out the most obvious
answer stop touching each other
there's nothing for that one i'm for
that one
well on these zoom calls make it much
easier i know i know until zoom figures
out a way to transmit a virus through
the computer you know the zoom call is
the great protector of of us all well
there you go but that but the truth is
it's going to be through a variety of
things so got to have really good
situational awareness that's testing
good clinical definitions clinicians
know what to look for when somebody
comes in
and has something that
is then we all
have really good vaccines now there are
a couple of vaccines that are out there
uh there's the genios vaccine which is
this vaccine it's a two-dose vaccine
and that's what's being distributed
right now but it's a really short supply
so we just don't have enough of it
uh and and
we we don't really know
how effective it's going to be in
particular in this scenario so every day
is a new set of data for you every day
is a new set of data and there are a lot
of knowledge gaps a lot of things we
have to understand we have to be humble
about what we know we have a good base
to start from but there's a lot more we
need to know and you know you've been in
academia it's really it takes a lot of
time to be able to get studies up and
running to be able to understand what's
happening i mean it's not just that
today
there's a new virus and you can turn
around and start it you have to write
protocols you have to get funding you
have to get ethics approval you have to
then have the logistics of rolling these
things out so it does take a lot of time
to get this done and this is the fact we
just don't have the funding and the
infrastructure in place to be able to do
what we need to do how transmissible is
this how can i get it actually how can i
not get it that's the real question the
real question yeah that's a really
excellent question it you know it
transmits through various routes um it's
not as transmissible as something like
stars cov2 virus that causes covid19 uh
it
it transmits most efficiently from
person to person skin to skin contact
sustained contact very close contact but
it can also transmit through what we
call foamites contaminated objects so
sheets towels
clothing
contaminated objects and and so
it's probably
much more contagious
the closer you are the the more virus
you're in contact with and so when
you're in contact with the with the
lesions that it causes um direct contact
that is probably the most efficient
route for transmission and that sexual
transmission is is a perfect example of
that i remember reading about the milk
maids they were very specific about it
they would have to have an open sore
while they were milking a cow with cow
pox
exactly so so if my skin is intact
uh how does someone else's monkey pox
get into my skin
well it might not i mean the skin can be
a good barrier it just it really depends
because you can have little skin
i'm a thick skin person okay
it could you could have you might not
know how thin your skin actually is
until you try you test it
so that that's one way i mean you could
also get it through respiratory
secretions you could be breathing it in
inhaling it um but it's it's there are a
variety of different ways to get it but
respiratory secretion that would be like
a sneeze or a cough right right so
bigger respiratory droplets that that
you might
expel when coughing or sneezing beyond
skin lesions how might monkey pots
also show up on your body monkey pox
also it infects it can you'll have
lesions in the oropharynx it can be down
your throat it can uh it causes what's
called a cytokine storm which is similar
cyrus kov2 also does that so you could
see you're going to have a massive
inflammatory response you know people
there there were just two cases of of uh
individuals in spain that died from um
from inflammation from from brain
inflammation from uh in in encephalitis
and and so this can be triggered by the
monkey barry triggered by monkey poss so
this can be a very serious disease
fatality rates are low
relative to other things and in
particular this this west african clade
not the congo basin played so this the
west african clade is what's circulating
and that tends to be milder but
there have been a few deaths and of
course the more cases that we see the
more likely that is and of course when
it gets into people who might have a
suppressed immune system
it could be a lot worse um can it cause
blindness and so it can it can and there
we've seen many instances of that in drc
uh where we have a fair number of cases
that that it can in fact cause blindness
if you can get if the virus gets into
your eye it can um really do some damage
so you know and and a reminder too it
isn't even just about these very acute
uh problems that that we have really
learned in the last several years how
important it is um how how viruses can
create a lot of long-term consequences
it isn't just about the acute infection
today which is substantial and painful
and scary and um and uh can be very
distressing but
you know we've we've learned a lot about
what viruses can do
uh and and causing long-term
consequences i think that once we get
more vaccine into the system and have
better surveillance and better testing
that we will we will have this
under much better control and i do not
anticipate that this will end up being
something like sars kovi ii where you
see
uh
that everybody's going to to have to be
taking precautions all the time that's a
very different kind of virus spreads
very differently
i know where i know we're getting out of
time but this is a philosophical
question because uh it
in america we tend to think of
infectious disease as something that we
need to protect ourselves from but the
more and more it looks like the world is
closing in on us so do we need to change
our thinking like it is an investment
for us to fight disease outside of this
country so that we can protect ourselves
inside the country
chuck absolutely i mean i i say this all
the time an infection anywhere is
potentially an infection everywhere
and we really do need to take that to
heart because you you live in a global
community yes and and what happens
elsewhere eventually
can affect you yourself at home
uh and and so that's why we we need to
be doing better we could have averted
this situation with monkey pox if we had
invested in helping countries like drc
be able to understand what was happening
and get in front of it but we failed to
do so and now we are paying the price
and this falls under i also say this
quite a bit it's much easier to stay out
of trouble than it is to get out of
trouble and now we are in get out of
trouble mode once again when we have the
writing on the wall for a very long time
well all i can say is you and your
fellow epidemiol epidemiologists
especially those who are specifically
focused on on
legislation that affects public health
um
i don't know where we'd be without you i
mean maybe we'd all still be in the
caves
dying of everything else that we look at
these woodcuts and
paintings of
you know the black plague and all of
this so i i i don't think you guys are a
hero worshipped as much as you should be
and let me add to that
that
chuck i don't know if you noticed the
candor with which anne spoke
of what they don't yet know
right okay that's how you know she's a
real academic but what happens is and
what's wrong with you you spent your
life and you still don't know i did two
hours of research and i know way more
than
the internet and i'm gonna have i'm
gonna have a podcast and i'm gonna tell
everyone what i do know and you should
listen to me that's what's going on no
stuff when i was on tick-tock and i just
learned everything about it
so so and my last question to you
because this is a
shared space in our two venn diagrams um
what do you do about misinformation
and
rampant
or people taking
what they think is information and
politically weaponizing it socially
culturally weaponizing it what do you do
as a public health professional
as a public health professional i try to
go on podcasts for example
audiences here very good
why didn't we think of that why didn't
we think of that
no but but it's really true what things
that you have to do are you have to get
out there in front of it and you have to
be vocal and you have to get in to as
many different places as you possibly
can and you don't always want to just
talk to the people who are agreeing with
you you want to talk to everybody and
you have to be willing to listen to
everybody too because it's reasonable to
have questions it's reasonable to to
to question
to question things including questioning
scientists but sometimes you end up with
with with social media today the speed
with which disinformation
gets out there
um it's it's very hard to combat it's
very hard to get in front of yeah that's
like the quote from mark twain um
uh in the early morning uh you know when
you wake up a lie can make it halfway
around the world before the truth has a
chance to put on its pants yeah
so i i i'm maybe misquoting it a little
bit but that's pretty much what he said
uh anyhow and this has been i don't say
delightful because you're telling us
about infectious diseases but it's been
highly enlightening and informative and
as monkey pox
continues to develop either to go back
in the can or escape even more can we
get you back on to get an update
absolutely i'll be happy to come on
anytime delighted okay thank you very
much for being on star talk chuck always
good to have you always a pleasure hey
and and and where do we find you on
social media
uh you can find me on twitter at a
remoin uh and
r i m o i n you bet and also on
instagram at anne ramoin
okay excellent we'll look for you there
keep us keep us enlightened keep us
informed uh keep us smart
and you've already been doing a great
job at that all right this has been star
talk i'm neil degrasse tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]